[Music]  imagine a device  that is the fastest most advanced  complex piece of technology  in the world but what if it wasn't just  a device  what if it was your new best friend hi  introducing the beebot  it connects you to the world like never  before  express yourself imagine without limits  create play and enter a new world  of friendship the bee bot let's make  friends wow happy late birthday barney  oh  dad you got me what  hi insert registered name i am your  your your my bee bot  be bought  there's something wrong with it it's not  meant to do that i'm not meant to do  that  i am for making friends does barney need  friends well yeah or fun fact he will  not survive middle school  [Music]  i am insert registered named best friend  out of my box  [Music]  god  [Music]